本就做错了，你的错折点在什么呢？你怎么能阻止你的老公和他的父母去联系呢？你想啥呢？人家是30年的感情，你就3年的感情，你用3年的感情挑战30年的感情，让他们别联系了。你想啥呢？我是挺迷茫的，就想请姐帮我分析一下到底怎么回事，应该怎么做。我现在的话是恋爱三年，结婚一年多，还没有备孕嘛，他爸就他一个。他后妈的话，有一个儿子归前夫家亲他一个人生活。后妈退休在家，当时他追了我个半年，我看他比较单纯真诚嘛，对我是挺体贴的，就跟他在一起了嘛。我们两个是属于彼此的初恋，我们当时一恋爱一年的时候就计划买房嘛，他爸当时就说，家里面现在住的房子是给他结婚买的，养他长大读书，家里面已经很不容易了，没有钱帮他在省会买房。但他考虑到省会那个房子就是工作、医疗、教育配套，还是决定在省会买。他自己当时存了17个，他爸后妈给了8个，他亲妈给了15，朋友借款了10个。买房钱的话，我就说虽然是你首付，但是，后面房款、房贷还有装修结婚都是我们俩一起承担。我手上有10个哈恋爱钱，我们俩也说彩礼8.8也可以，不要算在一起，就当我自己投入，作为我们结婚的共同买房，写两个人的名字，他就说就算先结婚再买。
啊，写了我名字，银行流水从他家卡里面出。他家里面出了钱，写我名字的话，也没办法向家里面交代。别人也会说我是为了房子才跟他结婚。听到这个的话，我有点懵，就觉得他比较现实，跟我考虑的方向不一样。朋友劝我，他说他说的虽然直接，但是实话，恋爱过程当中，他人品好，相处这么久，如果因为这个平开不值得，当时就是买房后还是跟之前一样会给我做饭。我们两个相互陪伴照顾。但是因为每个月要还房贷6000，就是欠款要还钱根本不够用。有些朋友的话，就介绍他的外省工作，工资没有1.5，我们就开始异地了。我们这去不张方便面，见过面的第一次见面的时候呢，我们也会就是买礼物啊什么之类的，他爸后妈也给我准备50块钱见面红包，他后妈儿子也给我准备了1000。后妈当时说就是邻居笑话他们没有用了，工济上面帮不了儿子，到现在还没有结婚，希望我能早点嫁过去。他把我当亲生女儿对待，异地半年呢，他总说看着别人一家团圆很孤单，希望我能来陪他，我就离开了一直生活的城市，来后到这个千里之外这边工作。这个期间我就跟我老公讲过，我说不要跟别人说我来到这个地方，毕竟我是女生，被别人知道不好。恋爱3年了，当时他让我感觉到比较安心，大家人都比较客气，我觉得也能接受这样的相处，就同意了求婚。这个时候，他后妈在电话里面就听他说，我要了要。
彩礼是8.8嘛，就是我妈妈那女儿让她拖着等我们年纪大了，看谁着急。因为我知道了，他就说他知道他们说的不对，不会按他们说的做。但是当时不知道怎么办，缺乏勇气，就只这么亲着，没有直接反驳。我当时就很害怕，就是想要的家庭是很睦的，相处，单纯的就跟他提了分手。他说舍不得，就说知道我在他心目当中第一位会对我好，让我只盼他保护好我就这样，我们就到了订婚。结婚后来的时候，结果他爸爸在返港的时候刚好结完婚就返岗嘛，就给他连着打四五个电话。内容的话，就是说我们跟在一个城市工作，不要异地，不要瞒着他们。如果说接触异地的话，让他们在家担心。前一两次，我在旁边听着还有点懵，就跟我老公讲，我说，你看，爸能跟我们换了，你告诉他我们会安排在一个城市的，让他不要担心。到第五次，看我还没有走，他爸就直接戳破了，就是告诉我就说他早就知道我在这边工作生活了，这个时候我才知道我的隐私被他在订婚之前告诉他爸了。这次之后，他爸就消停了，就没打电话过来，后来我就问我老公，我说为什么我们说好的保密，你还要跟他讲？他说他当时因为他想让他爸爸知道，我就对他真心很好，我们真心想在一起，所以躲着我跟他爸爸说的这个事情，让爸爸自己知道就可以了，不要再说从了。因为这个关系的话，突然间在这一个点上面，我们两个人就一下子。
就觉得好像在被幸福的时候一下子被戳破了，被伤害了，我那个时候开始就对他有情绪，我就会反对他跟他爸爸妈妈联系，觉得他爸爸妈妈不是真心为我们好，他当时刚开始他是同意的，这样持续了一个大半年。但是我一想到这个事情，或者说在生活当中碰到有类似的事情的时候，或者电视上面碰到类似的事情的时候，我就会埋怨他，跟他不高兴，发脾气。我们现在的话，就是结婚有一年多了嘛，我们从去年开始，其实我经历那个事情经历了有大半年，我就慢慢好转了嘛，又开始计划我们的未来，就想着我们俩好好在一起生活，还是觉得他还是挺好的。但是没想到就是到结婚了年的时候，他又有一次这样的事情发生了，就是选择了他爸爸和后妈，对他没有愧疚，而忽略我的感受。我当时就觉得挺难过的。你们俩到目前为止的话，真正的矛盾是什么？就是你来到了他的城市跟他同居了，但是你嘱咐他不要告诉他的爸爸妈妈，你已经在这边跟他同居了，可是他却违背了诺言，他告诉了他爸妈，你已经在这边了，就因为这件事儿，你觉得他没有跟你是站在一条线上的？你觉得他背叛了你的信任，是这个意思不对？因为刚结完婚，他爸爸就把这个事情说出来，为了结婚之前，我还能有我自己的考虑。可是刚结完婚。
他爸爸把这个事情说出来，我就觉得自己很被动。你都结了婚了，有啥被动的呢？就是我是很相信他的人。这事儿，我感觉问题出在什么呢？问题出在你高估了自己和男人的关系，低估了男人和父母的关系。男人和父母，他可能有30年的感情基础，你跟这个男人可能就3年的感情基础。他告诉他的爸爸妈妈，你跟他住在一起这个事儿不能叫背叛，这叫人性，对吧？首先，第一点，你跟他是否住在一起，这个点的话，本就没有那么重要。它不是一个说你的隐私的问题，咱就举个例子啊，说哎，我有什么妇科病，我觉得这是我的隐私，你不应该告诉你的爸爸妈妈，对吧？我跟你住在一起，本来我俩就是奔着结婚去的，我俩就是谈婚论嫁的，我俩就是过日子的。我跟你住在一起这个事儿，他不叫隐私。也就是说，这男的就算把这个事儿透露给他爸爸妈妈，这也不是什么十恶不赦的不值得原谅的大事儿。但是我跟他说好了，就是不要说，他也答应了，不说，这就是你自己对人性的认知是不成熟的，想少了吧。就这事儿，第一，他不是什么大事儿，不是说我有什么难言之隐，我有什么不能让别人知道的一个过往，或者说我有什么悲惨的经历，举个例子吧，说龙飞姐，我被猥亵过，或者我被强奸过，这事儿，如果我跟我老公说了，我说你别告诉你爸妈，他如果再。
告诉他爸妈的话，那这是原则性问题。但如果说我跟你住在一起这事，你别告诉你爸妈啊，多没面子。他可能没把这事儿当回事儿，没把这事儿当成一个太认真的事儿。他就说了，他说了吧，也无伤大雅，也不是什么原则性的大事儿。之后，我其实过了大半年的样子，我慢慢缓过来一点了，我又开始信任他，也开始计划以后，但是后面的时候又有一次他又选择了他爸跟他后妈两个人，又忽略我的感受，知道我会不高兴的那件事情，但还是会忽略我的感受，就那样去做。他说他会愧疚，会有心不忍。如果说我要拒绝他们的这种联系或者沟通，就让他们减少的话，他反正会很难过，就是很不舒服，他不愿意这个样子，可能如果说非要这样的话，我们两个人的关系都维持不了。那问我的问题是啥呀？他跟我讲，他说百善孝为先安，我这样是不对的。我如果说这样去阻止他们的关系，我们的关系就跑不了。那肯定的，你本身不应该阻止你做错了，姑娘，就算你给我花了钱了，你来我这问我要为你的利益考量，我也必须告诉你实话，你本就做错了，你的错的点在什么呢？你怎么能阻止你的老公和他的父母去联系呢？你想啥呢？人家是30年的感情，你就3年的感情。你用3年的感情挑战30年的感情，让他们别联系了。你想啥呢？我也不是说完全不联系。逢年过节我还是会回去，还是跟他一起客客气气的。
你说的吧，那么让我跟他爸妈别那么紧密的联系，是不是你说的吗？刚才原话对是的，你怎么能提这种要求呢？你提这种要求，你跟谁能过得好呢？你提这要求本身就是你认知低下的一种表现啊，本身就是你幼稚非常幼稚，跟你过日子那可太难了，怎么能提这种要求呢？提这种要求，第一不符合身份，第二，他也做不到啊，他做不到了，你又怪他，那你俩日子怎么过呢？是的，你要深刻认识到这一点。人和人之间是要讲交情的。人家30年的交情，你3年的交情，凭什么你的交情就一定要凌驾于人家30年交情之上呢？那他们30年交情也没有怎么相处，一直是分开的那种状态的，你又为这个男人做过什么呢？你凭什么你的交情就要凌驾于别人的关系之上呢？你可能当时觉得我对他真的是很好很好吧。那你告诉我你为他做过什么？你为他的前途做过什么？你为他的事业做过什么？你为他的个人成长做过什么？你凭什么说你对他好？你告诉我有什么例子可以举出来，你对他好，或者，我换个说法，我换个问法。他跟你在一起了之后，他有什么好处？他换好工作了吗？他有好的事业了吗？他跟你在一起的时候，他更幸福了吗？他跟你在一起了之后，你治愈了他的童年吗？他跟你在一起了之后，他成长了吗？他跟你在一起了之后，他变得更优秀了吗？他跟你在一起了之后。
他得到什么了吗？那你凭什么说你对他好？凭什么你的关系就要凌驾于其他关系之上？别生气啊，我就是希望你能明白，你的问题需要自己去攻克。第一，要充分的认识到，你要求他和他父母之间减少联系这个事儿是非常幼稚的行为，不应该这么干。而且，男生现在可能对你已经产生一定的排斥反感了。你如果想要化解这个排斥反感的话，只有自己认识到这一层才有可能维系这段关系。你要想维系的话，就必须要认识到自己。你要不想维系，你想换一个的话，那下一把咱们是不是也得要认清这个事实，才有可能处理好关系。不然的话，如果不会游泳，我换几个男的也过不好，换几个游泳池也照样淹死，是不是啊，其实中间还发生了很多事情，就是他爸爸和后妈就是属于那种就嘴巴上面说希望你们过得开心，但是中间会有很多去挑拨是非，就去破坏关系。你们本来就不生活在一起，我觉得这事儿啊，一定要有屏蔽力来把屏蔽这两个字给我打在公屏上，给你自己增加一点印象。什么叫屏蔽呢？就是以后啊，他们家的事儿，我少打听，他们家的关系，我少掺和，他们家的活动，我少参与。我就跟我老公搞好关系就可以了。我不挑他们家的毛病，我不寄希望于说公公婆婆在我怀孕啊，生孩子。
孩子的时候会给我打钱啊，会给我礼物啊，会给孩子买东西啊。我不寄希望于孩子满周岁的时候，公公婆婆会给我买个金锁呀，买个金项链啊。我不寄希望于他们会出钱出力，我就是不寄希望于他们会给我任何的帮助，我也就不去掺和他们家任何的事儿，就屏蔽以后我老公一聊起他公公婆婆的事儿，我就打岔，我说啊，挺好的啊，那个我想去拉个屎啊，挺好的啊，我尿尿啊，挺好的啊。等会儿我打个电话，就是他但凡说他家里的事儿的时候，我不掺和，我不讨论，我不听。就是跟你老公俩人过日子，不要有任何期待，就屏蔽，不要有任何期待，期待他们说你好，期待他们认为你好，期待他们夸你，期待他们在你怀孕生孩子的时候给你什么帮助，不，我没有期待，不是没有期待。我唯一看的就是我老公这个人，他是怎么做的。你对你老婆的期待也要调整，你不能期待你老公跟他爸妈就是少联系了，然后什么事都站在你这一头了。你跟他爸妈少联系，你跟他爸妈没交集，你跟他爸妈没有矛盾，他就不用选，但是他爸妈也在这个关系就是说减少关系，对吧？对，才有可能这日子能过下去。好吧，好的，你继续好，拜拜啊，这姑娘还挺好的，我讲话这么激动，讲话这么难听，人家她也不生气，就表示。
什么他心里还是有肚量的？他如果认识到这个点了，知道这个点了他心里是有度量的。他能接受，他有度量，能接受他就有可能调整他的相处模式。真的，你要换别的姑娘的话，我这么说话这么难听，人家早生气了，早就要求退钱了，都去给我点关注。